si vous circulez ch à paris dans les
départements de seine saint denis ou du
val-de-marne ne vous êtes comme moi
obligé de porter un masque un masque qui
était au mois d'avril
inutile et pas nécessaire et bien
aujourd'hui il fait figure d'armes
numéro un pour le gouvernement pour
lutter contre la propagation du côté de
19 à compter du vendredi 28 août à 8
heures le port du masque sera
obligatoire pour tous les piétons
circulant dans les espaces publics les
utilisateurs de vélos deux roues
trottinette et autres engins de mobilité
personnelle motorisés oh non les usagers
circulant à l'intérieur des véhicules à
moteur voitures des particuliers
camionnettes ou poids lourds des
professionnels seront dispensés de cette
obligation
sous la pression de la mairie de paris
notamment la préfecture de police fait
marche arrière ce matin concernant les
cyclistes et les joggeurs finalement ils
ne seront pas concernées par
l'obligation du port du masque mais des
questions restent en suspens porter le
masque partout en extérieur d'accord
mais at on le droit de le retirer pour
manger pour fumer ou est-ce que c'est
aussi interdite dans les rues de paris
les avis sont mitigés entre ceux qui
n'étaient pas au courant de l'obligation
du port du masque dès ce vendredi 8
heures et ceux qui trouvent là mesures
trop contraignantes
je pense pas que ce soit obligatoire
tout le temps revendre si tu veux manger
on peut l'enlever trois secondes pour
manger mais il faut leur mettre quoi
tant que je pense que tant que la
personne
elle pense arômes et grimaces dans le
corps à la fini de faire ce qu'elle a à
faire normalement ça devrait être bon je
porte le masque quand il ya une presse
dans la rue effectivement je module en
fonction de l'affluence
je sais bien que c'est obligatoire mais
on a un petit peu de libre arbitre
encore je comprends dans ce pays
faut espérer honnêtement j'avais pas vu
passer l'info pour aujourd'hui je
pensais c'est encore avec 10 as reste un
et dans des lieux obligatoire est bon
j'ai déjà fait mais je le porte à chaque
fois qu'on me dit qu'il faut le porter
voilà c'est un manque d'information mais
recule pas voilà alors c'est un matériau
prendre des masques
j'ai juste à vous en sortir mais on va
prendre des mois ce qu on va faire
simple il suffit d'un petit paumé et
c'est pour ça va il fait froid
aujourd'hui mais ça va mais quand il
fait très chaud
moi je serai avec le basque on peut pas
respirer quoi c'est à dire pour nous
c'est un peu entre guillemets rajuste
aussi d'avoir une amende parce qu'on a
on vient de retirer deux minutes ne
masque pour parce qu'on avait besoin de
respirer
je sais que j'ai bien un reportage par
williams et une dame sur les infos qui
est à retirer une minute à ces prix sont
135 euros d'amendé
c'est un peu compliqué donc il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens
avec cette crise aussi ça c'est un peu
dur c'est une question de logique
j'ai déduit que quand on est assis qu'on
consomme on peut enlever parce qu'on ne
peut pas consommer avec le masque quand
on arrête de manger on veut leur maître
etc poursuit mais personnellement je
suis pas fumeur dont je pense qu'on peut
s'en passer mais j'avoue que c'est un
peu compliqué je sais pas trop comment
positionner
peut-être que ça mériterait plus de
précisions et d'ici à ce que la
préfecture de police de paris clarifie
sa position elle sachez que le non port
du masque est puni d'une amende de 135
euros amende qui peut monter jusqu'à
3750 euros en cas de récidive